tonight about an hour and a half ago i
spoke to former new york city mayor rudy
giuliani here's that interview
former new york city mayor and former
federal prosecutor
and attorney to president trump rudy
giuliani
mr mayor there's a lot to unpack here
now
my underst my understanding is
a fairer violation is very specific
at the time when we had the impeachment
of the president over the phone call
that the infamous phone call of hearsay
anonymous whistleblower
uh you were investigating the issues
involving joe biden
leveraging a billion taxpayer dollars
and his son hunter and the firing this
prosecutor
was that the only reason you were
investigating ukraine and involved with
ukrainians
100 i was this was a
two years before the election had
nothing to do with the election i was
brought into it uh when the allegations
of corruption in the ukraine were given
to me
which included corruption by joe biden
uh
as well as a tremendous amount of dirt
that was dug up on
uh on on the trump's which hillary paid
for
and uh as in the course of that uh i was
told by the ukrainians you know he
he he got a big bro biden made a big
bribe here
he uh pushed the president of ukraine to
get rid of the case
on one of the crookedest guys in in uh
ukraine
zloshevsky and he made a big score
so you know this money for for hunter
bite is not for hunter biden
we we we got that tape of joe you heard
hunter on good morning america
do you think he deserved the millions
from all these countries with no
experience
yeah yeah but they want me out because
i'm the one who uncovered it and brought
it to light
and i came on your show and i talked
about it and also the hard drive
was given to me because the guy didn't
trust anybody else
he didn't trust the fbi because the fbi
had it for
almost a year and did nothing with it so
i want to get to the very question that
was my question
you did nothing that would would at all
trigger any fairer violation whatsoever
and that your work and investigative
work had to do with
barisma joe biden withholding a billion
dollars the prosecutor
and hunter's lack of experience
at 100 percent i i've in fact in the
course of my career i have turned down
multiple
opportunities to lobby to do pharah and
when i do do contracts i i very often if
it's
any issue i put in a i put in a clause
saying i will not do it
uh i was i was representing the
president of the united states the whole
world knew that
the whole world knew it and this is i
mean
this is totally done because
they want to destroy my credibility
because i have that entire hard drive
i have the whole thing i put it out to
the new york post
and since then they have been
persecuting me they've been threatening
me
they have done everything they can to
destroy every business relationship i
have
they have put out all kinds of false
stories the most recent of which
was the ridiculous story that i was
briefed by the fbi
a total lie by three newspapers who
spend most of their time
lying if they're lying about that
isn't it obvious they're lying about
everything if the fbi is lying to them
about briefing me
well don't let me ask you lying about
the rest of it
i want to go to this issue about about
prosecutors accessing your icloud
account in early 2019.
this is leading right up into the
impeachment if i'm not mistaken
and professor dershowitz talked about it
this weekend
and was very outspoken and
he said in banana republics in castro's
cuba when a candidate loses the
presidency they go after the candidate
they go after his lawyers they go after
his friends
and speaking directly about your case a
search warrant on a lawyer doctor or
priest you can't use search warrants
you don't use them when people have
privileged information
on cell phones and computers you use a
subpoena
and he believes you have you were you
you and your attorney were told that the
surveillance of you happened in 2019
yeah here's what i was told i'll tell
i'll try to repeat it exactly
my attorney robert costello was told
that they
obtained a covert warrant and the date
of the warrant was from may 1st 2018
until november 4 2019. they took
everything on my
icloud from that period of time now
interestingly uh may 1st
is when i started representing donald
trump they wanted nothing on me before
that
so you can't say that their main
interest wasn't donald trump
so the date just about the day that i
begin representing
him is the day they go invade my icloud
so
try telling somebody that it wasn't to
get the material on donald trump
and then they have a year and a half of
material all through my representation
of him
during the complete fraud of a collusion
thing and then all during my
representation of them during the
ukrainian thing
up until november 4. they have had that
for a year and a half
and haven't been been able to produce a
single allegation
against me i've had it for a year and a
half
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else